hello and welcome to this episode of the
apogee accelerator Series in this video
I will be showing how to use apogee to
extract different variables from the
response body in XML and Json and how to
modify the response headers using the
out-of-the-box policies
let's start with how we built this proxy
in apogee as you can see in this diagram
we have our API consumers on the left
hand side and a Target backend on the
right
we are using a mock Target API for this
example aperture sits in between the two
apogee has 60 plus out-of-the-box
policies to do things like Appliance
security traffic management
Etc you can then apply these policies to
the requests or response
for this sample I will be focusing on
the response flow the mock Target API
contains an XML payload
we use the extract variables policy as a
first step to extract subsets of data
from the XML response body
later on WE Leverage The XML to Json
policy to convert the XML response from
the target server to Json
we use again the extract variables
policy to extract subsets of data from
the now converted Json stream
finally we use the assigned message
policy to set the response headers with
the extracted fields you will find this
accelerator in our public GitHub
repository that is linked in the
description below in order to deploy
this sample you will need an apigee X
instance provision with external access
as a user you will need access to deploy
proxies in apogee these can be granted
through the apogeeoric admin role or the
API and developer admin roles you will
also need the command line tools listed
here if you're using Google Cloud shell
these are all already included we have
also included a cloud show tutorial
which will guide you throughout the
entire process once you click the link
it will take you directly to your Cloud
shell console clone the repository and
open the step-by-step tutorial to help
you get started
the first step is to make sure that
you're logged in with the right user
then change the directory to the current
extract variable sample
use the built-in Editor to open the
environment sh file and set the
different environment variables for your
gcp project apogee external hostname as
well as the apigee environment where you
would like the sample to be deployed
close the editor and save the file then
Source the environment file to set the
environment variables in Cloud shell now
hit start
next let's create and deploy the apogee
resources necessary to test the extract
variables proxy this script creates a
sample API proxy
the script also tests that the
deployment and configuration has been
successful
now let's go to the gcp console to see
that everything was deployed correctly
as you can see the extract variables
proxy has been deployed
let's use the debug tool in apogee to
see the incoming requests
as you can see we get a 200 OK status
code and we can see every policy being
executed as the request comes in
if we click on the response flow the
first thing we will find is the XML
payload from our backend
then we use the extract variables policy
to extract the different fields like
city and state and store them in
variables
in the following step we use the XML to
Json policy to transform the XML into
Json
after that we use the extract variables
policy again to extract the first name
last name and store them in variables
but this time around from a Json payload
this is just to show how the policy
works for both XML and Json
finally we use the assign message policy
to set the response headers with the
variables we created before
the final response sent to the client is
a Json object
if we go back to the tutorial and click
through we will find a cleanup script
that will remove the proxy from our
apogee instance
we hope that you found this sample
useful and if you liked the video please
hit the like button below you can also
subscribe to our channel for more apogee
videos if you have questions please post
them in the apogee community